aber lassen sie uns jetzt zuerst auf die
stadt schauen auf die ganz europa blickt
paul wie gehen die mehr wie geht es den
menschen wie gehen die menschen mit dem
krieg um und wie ist die versorgungslage
in kiew vor ort
janina die menschen haben sich langsam
an den krieg gewöhnt auch wenn man sich
schwer an einen krieg gewöhnen kann aber
viele wenn sie die sie reden wie gerade
eben auch wieder hören gehen nicht mehr
in den keller weil sie sagen das ist
kein leben wenn wir jedes mal in den
keller rennen finden wir keinen schlaf
mehr können am nächsten tag gar nichts
machen also man gewöhnt sich daran
dadurch steigt natürlich auch die gefahr
also hier in kiew gab es gestern
einschläge in einem wohngebiet in
städten wie mario pohl ist es anders als
in kirchen sind die menschen den ganzen
tag im keller weil es nicht anders ist
weil hunderte bomben dort fallen und die
versorgungslage in kiew die wird
schwieriger tatsächlich man merkte dass
bestimmte produkte nicht mehr zu haben
sind insbesondere frischeprodukte die
supermärkte leer gekauft sind allerdings
gibt es noch eine verbindung in den
süden der stadt ist es frei da gibt es
freie wege und es gibt auch noch einen
zug der zwischen lemberg und kiew
erklärt der einerseits flüchtlinge
rausbringt und andererseits menschen
hierher kommen wollen bzw produkte die
herkommen wollen hier einbringt
der russische präsident putin paul der
hat heute eine rede gehalten eine
propaganda rede gehalten die
unterbrochen wurde was man aber nicht
gesehen hat was hat es damit auf sich
es gab eine bizarre propaganda show so
muss man es nennen im stadion in moskau
in moskau da wurden viele leute offenbar
auch hin gekappt das habe ich gerade bei
den kollegen von bbc gelesen also
arbeitete er da eigentlich gar nicht so
richtig hin wollten aber die mehr oder
weniger gedrängt wurden dort hinzugehen
und wladimir putin hat dort eine
propaganda rede gehalten die man sich so
kannte hat die einheit beschworen
russlands in dem krieg und hat davon
gesprochen dass hier ein genozid verübt
werden sollte also hut sein seine lüge
über einen angeblichen völkermord noch
einmal wiederholt um damit zu
rechtfertigen warum russland dort ist
und dann plötzlich war die rede weg das
bild weg im staatsfernsehen und es ging
wieder von vorne los wo irgendwelche
russischen bands gespielt haben man weiß
es bis jetzt nicht möglicherweise ein
hacker-angriff jemand der bewusst dieses
signal stören wollte jemand der versucht
hat sozusagen wladimir putin zu
schädigen denn das war natürlich eine
seiner wichtigsten reden ja in einer
zeit in der krieg geführt wird und ein
krieg geführt wird der ja für russland
momentan nicht besonders gut aussieht
weil man die ziele die wladimir putin
hat sind nämlich die eroberung von kiew
und der ukraine in wenigen tagen oder
wochen nicht erreicht
aber paul täuscht der eindruck oder
hatte das ganze eine neue qualität von
inszenatorischen pomp und größenordnung
man kennt ja die regelmäßigen
pressekonferenzen von wladimir putin die
im goldenen gepränge stattfinden wo er
dann die riesigen türen aufgehalten
bekommt und rein marschiert das hat er
heute jetzt schon wirklich stadion
charakter
vor hintergründen deutscher geschichte
hat man da immer ein gewisses schaudern
solcher stadion geschichten noch dazu zu
kriegszeiten
ist so etwas schon öfter vorgekommen und
das abbrechen wäre jetzt nicht
unwahrscheinlich wenn man davon ausgeht
dass die ganze veranstaltung
zeitversetzt gesendet worden ist so was
gehört eigentlich zum standard in der
sicherheits betonten regime
also ich kann mich an nichts ähnliches
erinnern ralf insbesondere nicht während
des meiden oder des krieges auf der krim
dass man versucht hätte so eine stimmung
zu erzeugen ist zeigt ein bisschen in
welcher ecke putin möglicherweise ist
und was die sicherheitsfrage angeht das
finde ich sehr interessant denn wir und
andere schreiben wir darüber dass
wladimir putin sich immer wieder in
verschiedenen bunkern versteckt hat dass
er den zugang zur öffentlichkeit kaum
sucht also ich habe mich hier mit
ukrainischen politikern unterhalten da
waren einige davon überzeugt das war
nicht der echte putin das muss ein
doppelgänger gewesen sein das passt
nicht zu seinem auftreten bislang also
viele mythen die wir aber wahrscheinlich
nicht klären können sondern nur
spekulieren können frau kipping sie
verbinden eine enge persönliche
beziehung mit russland sie können auch
russisch sprechen auf jeden fall mich in
einem interview gelesen ist sie gesagt
haben für den smalltalk reicht es für
eine simultanübersetzung nicht
wahrscheinlich können sie es dann doch
noch etwas besser man geht er eher ein
bisschen zurück mit seinen eigenen
fähigkeiten immer um nicht anzugeben
aber die frage ist natürlich wie
empfinden sie gerade den russischen
präsidenten
also zunächst muss ich sagen mir blutet
natürlich das herz zum einen wenn man
sieht was putin den menschen in der
ukraine antut zum zweiten auch was ich
das wissen was jetzt auch den menschen
in russland passiert ich finde es auch
wichtig dass er von putins krieg
sprechen und nicht vom krieg der russen
gegen die ukraine weil wir sehen ja auch
dass auch in russland menschen gibt die
sehr sehr viel riskieren und trotzdem
demonstrieren für ein ende dieses
krieges allein das aussprechen des
wortes krieges ist ja dort mit mehreren
jahren gefängnis inzwischen bedroht und
ich weiß auch inzwischen das leider der
hass den putin seht dass der auch schon
hierzulande niederschlägt und auch in
den schulhöfen niederschlägt dass ich
habe neulich mit menschen gesprochen die
russischen gemeinde sind wo ein kind
dessen eines elternteil russisch spricht
dieselbe ukrainische geflüchtete
aufgenommen haben und die auf dem
schulhof angegriffen werden dafür und
für mich ist es so wichtig zum einen in
aller entschiedenheit
putin zu verurteilen auch zu schauen
inwieweit man da die sanktion die
wirklich die norma schärfen kann dass
man die kriegsherren im kreml trifft und
zum anderen ganz deutlich zu sagen
niemand wirklich niemand kann was dafür
dass er die selbe sprache wie der
aggressor putin spricht und es sollte
auf keinen fall ein kind auf dem
schulhof dafür büßen müssen
das wirst du vermutlich ganz genauso
sehen paul aber hier die frage an dich
wie groß ist denn die sympathie wladimir
putin in seinem land kann man wirklich
sagen putin ist nicht russland die
stimmung
also erstmal bin ich ja in der ukraine
deswegen ist es schwer für mich die
stimmung jetzt in russland zu
beschreiben aber tatsächlich ist es das
auch ein großes diskussionsthema hier
etwas vor kipping dort anspricht und
vorweg geschickt natürlich dürfen kinder
nicht auf schulhöfen deshalb gemobbt
werden und solche fälle da müssen wir
alles gegen thun absolut auf der anderen
seite finde ich ein bisschen einfach nur
von putins krieg zu sprechen und ich
empfinde das auch als falsch wenn wir
peter tiede unserem korrespondenten dort
zu hören wenn ich mir meinungsumfragen
anschaue wenn ich mir anhöre wie freunde
von mir hier in der ukraine mit menschen
in russland telefonieren und die dann
sich als nazis beschimpfen lassen müssen
weil die propaganda dort im wirkt und
wenn wir uns die meinungsumfragen
anschauen dann steht ja die große
mehrheit des russischen volkes hinter
wladimir putin unabhängig davon haben
sie ihn gewählt sie haben sich auch
nicht gegen aufgelehnt als 2014 hier die
krim annektiert wurde ganz im gegenteil
da gab es noch mehr jubel also einfach
zu sagen das ist da der böse diktator
und der hat jetzt alle irgendwie
da unter sich und die können nichts tun
und die tun uns alle so leid und es gäbe
so einen wahnsinnigen widerstand in
russland also bei allem respekt vor
kipping aber den sehe ich noch nicht
natürlich ist es gefährlich auf die
straße zu gehen es gab kleinere proteste
aber das ist jetzt eine massenbewegung
gebe und dass man schon sagen kann dass
ich da alle gegen putin auflehnen das
ist glaube ich nicht der fall das habe
ich ja nicht behauptet herrnsheimer ich
will nur sagen wer in russland sich
entscheidet auf die straße dazu gehen
und ich sehe die bilder von den
demonstrationen sind jetzt keine
massendemonstration aber muss wissen wer
das macht für sich selber auch ein
großes risiko in kauf das heißt also da
muss es schon eine unglaubliche
überzeugungen geben ansonsten was die
stimmungslage anbelangt in russland die
macht mir natürlich sorgen aber schon
seit vielen jahren weil ich eben noch
nicht sehe dass es dort wirklich eine
richtig große massen was es gibt für
eine demokratische weltoffene menschen
rechts orientierte alternative zu putin
da das würde ich so beschreiben als ein
großes problem für für die russische
situation aber ich finde immer nur man
darf nicht alle menschen jetzt mit
verhaften natürlich gibt es ein system
putin putins krieg ist übrigens der
titel ihres senders mit noch um das hier
nochmal zu zitieren aber glaube wir sind
ganz gut beraten da etwas zu
differenzieren ja putin ist gewählt die
frage ist inwieweit gab es wirklich eine
breite demokratische alternative die
auch eine chance hatte sich bekannt zu
machen unter dem regime von putin frau
kipping sehen schon 2014 ja auch und
2015 kritik an wladimir putin geübt und
dann russland das gab in ihrer partei
manchmal nicht so gute laune muss man
sagen habe ich den alten berichten auch
gelesen was war denn die ersten
alarmzeichen bei ihnen selbst wo sie
gesehen haben okay das ist nicht gut der
weg den er geht
ja was man vielleicht einmal sagen muss
ich bin ja nach meinem abitur für ein
jahr nach russland gegangen und habe
dort ein freiwilliges soziales jahr
gemacht ich hatte da er mit
italienischen münchen zu tun und jungen
jugendlichen die ich quasi als pädagogen
betreuen sollte und ich hab halt ende
der 90er jahre sankt petersburg erlebt
es eine sehr weltoffene stadt wo im also
ganz viel in bewegung war und habe dann
über die jahre hinweg gemerkt wie es in
der gesellschaft wieder ein
zusammenziehen gibt wie es
wirklich schwulenfeindlichkeit dann auch
regierungsprogramm wurde und und und und
habe gemerkt wie menschen die ich
getroffen habe bei einem seminar wo es
um sozialproteste ging meistert
sozialkürzungen gab und dann erlebt habe
wie die mutter mehr es gab tage da haben
wir uns nicht getraut rauszugehen zu der
demo die wir gemacht haben weil wir
dachten okay wenn wir rausgehen werden
wir sofort verhaftet das waren so für
mich die alarmzeichen die da schon
geklungen haben für mich war immer
wichtig in der linken sehr deutlich zu
machen dass es bei uns nicht zweierlei
maß geben darf wenn es um menschenrechte
geht und dass man da auch nichts zu
relativieren hat das hat mir nicht nur
freunde gemacht also russia today putins
propagandasender hat dann auch so ein
patt roller auf mich geschickt die sag
ich mal als nicht nur freundliche sachen
über mich gesagt haben aber mir war das
wichtig diesen punkt zu setzen und auch
klar zu ziehen dass die linke in dieser
frage steht luke stellini origin
carrasso pavillon bruce key ich habe
lernen müssen
nicht gerne gelernt auch wegen der
vielen fälle aber 816 fälle ergänzt noch
schlimmeres das stimmt uns fällt mir
leichter aber das ist egal das
interessante ist natürlich dass viele
russen diese 90er jahre die sie so als
befreiend erlebt haben gerade
traumatisch in erinnerung haben anfang
an k s unter jelzin die oligarchen die
zu der zeit stark geworden sind und
jeder bedient hat am start das ist etwas
was sowohl putin nach wie vor als eine
nahtoderfahrung des russischen
riesenreiches mit sich herumträgt und
was eben viele leute auch als sehr
unkomfortabel armut alkohol grassierten
nicht zuletzt in der obersten spitze
jetzt sind wir schwerer alkoholiker
das haben viele nicht so in erinnerung
und aber das sind die das sind anfang
und mitte der 90er jahre gab eine kurze
phase wo das eine öffnung gab und man
auch darüber vielleicht so sie also das
war immer armut war dort man darf sagen
dass ein gewisser wunsch nach stärke
schon auch in der russischen
gesellschaft tief verankert ist man
schätzt keine führer die sich schwach
zeigen und dann gab es zum anfang der
90er jahre auch noch ein ganz anderes
problem viele russen sagte damals wir
haben im letzten jahrhundert zwei kriege
gewonnen den ersten und den zweiten und
wir sind eigentlich immer die verlierer
geblieben am ende zogen wenn die truppen
aus deutschland ab 994 und deutschland
verpflichtete sich ein paar wohnungen zu
bauen das war ein klacks mit dem feuer
denn für das reiche deutschland aber den
lebensstandard der breiten masse in
russland hat das alles nicht verändert
und
das ist schon auch ein trauma gegenüber
dem westen was man versucht in einigen
kreisen mit nationalstolz zu puffern und
das ist immer ungut
sie erleben jetzt auch dass viele
menschen dieses land kommen nicht aus
russland vor allem aus der ukraine und
anderen staaten erleben sie denn da
jetzt auch diesen russen hass oder den
hass auf die russische gesellschaft nein
also bislang bis dann kann man das auch
nur schwer differenzieren weil die
meisten mit denen wir polizeilicher zu
tun haben die hier ankommen in
deutschland sind halt ukraine oder haben
auch einen ukrainischen hintergrund also
das kann ich so nicht bestätigen mir
macht das aber auch große sorge was frau
kipping gerade gerade erzählt hat wenn
es tatsächlich schon soweit ist dass in
den schulen und in den kindergarten dort
aus den elternhäusern raus ukrainische
und russische kinder sich da schon auf
deutsch gesagt in die wolle bekommen
dann müssen in jeder senatsverwaltung
alle alarmglocken schellen und man muss
da mit prävention jetzt darauf reagieren
und nicht warten bis da bis da schlimmes
in den schulen passiert habt es gab ja
sogar brandanschlägen in berlin auf eine
soft schule eine bilinguale schule also
das ist schon fall wohl auch inzwischen
der staatsschutz ermitteln muss